smoke bellows from the theater mario
paul after it was hit by a bomb
days before a satellite image showed the
russian word for children written in
large white letters at both ends of the
building
but that did not stop it being targeted
mario paul a russian plane intentionally
dropped a super powerful bomb on a drama
theater in the city center hundreds of
people were hiding there from shelling
the building is destroyed the number of
casualties is not yet known
across mario paul similar images of
devastation
russian forces have besieged the city
for over a week now cutting off
civilians from food water electricity
and medical supplies
this local hospital has to operate with
constant shelling around it
inside a desperate scene unfolds
civilians lay injured and medical staff
do what they can
those who couldn't be saved have been
taken to the basement and covered in
blankets
this little one only lived 22 days
before he died
right now there is no morgue where they
can store the bodies
all the other hospitals have been bombed
and no one can collect them there's no
emergency services there's nobody i
don't know where we will put them how we
will bury them
a few have been able to escape mario
paul but even that's not safe
ukrainian authorities say russian forces
fired on a convoy fleeing mario paul
leaving several people injured
and for more now joining us from ukraine
is olhan flamenco she is with the
canadian institute for ukrainian studies
at the university of alberta in canada
she's in kiev tonight and
oh look can you hear me
yes i can hear you we we appreciate you
taking the time and we want to let our
viewers know um you're sitting in the
dark right now
um because people in kiev have been told
to keep their lights off
um to protect themselves and to not
attract any
airstrikes um
talk to me what's going on where you are
right now
it's seemingly quiet today was a good
day it was a sunny day there was a lot
of people there were a lot of people on
the streets because we had a long curfew
so today people you know went out to
enjoy some fresh air and it's you know
we can hear our our defense air defenses
working
that gives us reassurance that we're
safe
occasionally
some debris from the missile
or in
some shelling
damages buildings we had a few buildings
damaged and a few civilians killed by
shelling and by debris of the missiles
but otherwise we feel that kia was safe
from the ground attack now
we're not so safe from the air yeah yeah
that's that's unfortunately very true
and i understand that um just before the
invasion began
you left canada you return to ukraine
that's where you're from to help take
care
of your elderly
father you're there with him now i
understand he's doing better but you're
in the middle of a war zone we know a
lot of people are trying to get out of
the country
are you and your father are you trying
or do you have plans to
leave uh
no
one concern is my father's health
because he had a stroke so i'm not sure
that traveling any distance you know in
fact trains or even in a private car
would be safe for him and second that he
refuses to leave
and
this is the case with a lot of people a
lot of my friends there is a number of
reasons why people do not want to leave
again they have elderly relatives who
refuse to live they have maybe
children who are in the territorial
defense forces there are people who just
say we're going to stay this is our land
this is our home we're not living
and uh people just do not believe that
kiev's going to fall they believe that
he was going to stand
you up
you're a ukrainian scholar
and you know the history of your country
did you expect
in the last three weeks
to see such a strong sense of national
unity and even resistance emerge
i i expected that because uh basically i
think the revolution of dignity um which
occurred in
2014 showed that ukrainians have a
strong sense of national identity and
strong sense of civic identity they are
freedom
loving people
they appreciate that they have their own
state where they can you know you know
build their own life according to their
own rules
and i expected i expected the resistance
to be strong
and we know that you're researching the
holotamor which is when
stalin used famine intentionally in the
1930s to kill millions of ukrainians
that was a real trauma for the country
but it also provided glue for
national identity this invasion by
russia is it an analogous event
in a way because we can speak about
trauma on many levels there is like a
physical direct trauma from observing
what is going on now from observing
depth the destruction the
you know the unfairness of what's going
on and there is such a thing as what we
call vicarious trauma that we relieve
our past traumas
and we see what's going on now in the
same terms as assault not only
on ukrainians as individuals but on our
political nation and on our cultural
nation you know on
because putin denies ukrainians the
right to exist and he denies ukraine the
right to exist as a state
so for us it's uh as holodomor
was an assault on ukraine as a nation
you know some people disagree but i
believe ukrainians were targeted because
they were freedom loving and because
stalin wanted to break their opposition
to collectivization and to the soviet
rule so he starred them so now
yeah sure yeah but just before we run
out of time i just want to ask you
you're a historian you you know you
study the past but um let's look into
the future for just a moment um what
kind of country do you think ukraine is
going to
be when it comes out of this war
i
think
ukrainians are now a forward-looking
nation we remember our past traumas but
we're determined to overcome this we are
determined to overcome the victimization
and i think people are now saying we're
going to rebuild better
we're going to rebuild at any cost we're
going to prevail even though it's early
in the war and i think that ukrainians
want to be
the nation that people are proud to
identify with you know like mila kunis
all of a sudden decided that she's a
ukrainian because it's cool to be
ukrainian so i think ukrainians want to
be perceived as cool contemporary
and freedom loving
hola flamenco
joining us tonight from kiev although we
appreciate you taking the time at such a
dangerous time to share your story with
us we wish you and your father all the
best and we hope
that
very soon you'll be able to turn the
lights back on thank you
thank you so much thank you for having
me
you